[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy monday morning
happy
happy monday morning
welcome welcome welcome to the tony
michaels podcast
live
noon eastern 11 central every single
weekday here on youtube twitter and
twitch thanks for joining us for another
fun filled week
a political and social commentary no
rules no boundaries as it says in the
intro
we have some great things coming up this
week uh we have a great interview uh
actually we're gonna have a couple uh
interviews this week i believe that will
air
so don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel you're definitely gonna
wanna do that if you're a new listener i
know we have new listeners out there all
the time
as we are just joining the mind as touch
media network everyone knows big big big
big news
fantastic news we appreciate the my
zealous brothers over there at midas
touch
maybe we'll have some more personalities
you guys see the uh i watched a little
bit of the five minute news weekend show
the weekend show with uh politics girl
lee mcgowan
i just reposted the
the link
in my
in my timeline so go over and check that
out after the show after the show
but you know we're live here every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific
for all of you out there in the pacific
time zone or mountain time are you guys
i'm telling you this [ __ ] time change
thing huh
i tell you what
i don't know about it
i mean i like i like that you get more
light in the evening right i like that
part that's fine whatever [ __ ] whatever
but this it [ __ ] me up this morning
yesterday morning not so much you know
it's sunday what are you gonna do i mean
unless you're you know like a churchgoer
or something
but i'm not
so you know you just you you manage that
first morning because it's on sunday
monday got you all [ __ ] up
it's all turned around you're not in the
same spot the clock ain't right
it just
it's not something we should still be
doing i don't know that's my opinion
i don't know
the goddamn time zones is it does it is
is arizona the only state that doesn't
do it like arizona's like yeah [ __ ] off
we're not doing that [ __ ] we're not
changing our time you can go to hell
like arizona just as [ __ ] you we're not
we're not doing that whole time change
thing
maybe all the states should just decide
not to do it then we wouldn't have to do
the [ __ ] and i i'm not sure which time
i'd rather have permanent right
either the daylight savings time which
is now right you're saving daylight you
know you're extending the light into the
evening i'm not sure if i like that part
or i like the you know the normal [ __ ]
i'm not sure
i don't know you tell me you tell me
what the hell we're supposed to do maybe
we'll put a poll up you guys can vote on
which way you want it to go
welcome everyone i know i know the time
is off this morning but welcome welcome
welcome we have vicky here kathy carter
kaelin robin debbie
uh snick
mj
uh kevin
we got the eye guy hi guys here today um
mayo good morning mayo
everyone's here good morning good
morning good morning
good morning
um
let's see do we have any any
opinions on the
on the time zone or the time change
excuse me time zone
anyone out there from arizona that's in
the [ __ ] you time change
land
i don't know
we got a lot of stuff to get to today
uh
remy says here [ __ ]
daylight savings
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them and it's it's only like it's
only like the first
couple days right like that first week
you're just completely [ __ ] you're
completely [ __ ] you don't know what
time it is you know you're not sure
where to go how to go when you're
supposed to go you have no [ __ ] clue
that first week it just [ __ ] with your
head
and then you know after the week 10 days
14 days you get used to the [ __ ] you get
used to it
and then they [ __ ] it up again they [ __ ]
it's always [ __ ] up maybe we should
just like change the time and
what we should do is just change the
time every [ __ ] month just every
month like at turn it back three hours
and maybe there should be like a lottery
wheel
you know what i'm saying if we're gonna
[ __ ] with everyone's minds and their
schedules let's just let's really [ __ ]
with it let's have fun let's play like a
[ __ ] game or something
you know we just spend the wheel to see
how many hours we're supposed to turn
the clock back or turn the clock forward
and we just do that we just do that we
just have fun with it it's like a
national game that we play time game
stop with the daylight savings [ __ ] and
again i'm not sure if i prefer like this
time
or the the the normal time i don't know
i don't know
says give me more light
give me more light
i saw the light
a lot stuff going on in the news today
uh dolly parton has refused her uh
candidacy into the rock and roll hall of
fame i guess uh coke industries
are [ __ ] traitors
ah who to guess that
who to come up with that one candace
owens is trending i'm not sure why it's
probably because she's a dumb buck
tulsi gabbard is also a russian
that's why she's trending randy
rainbow's trending he's got a new video
out and we'll watch that i watched part
of it i haven't watched him and watched
the whole thing
but i watched part of it and before we
came on pfizer is requesting
uh
that we get a fourth round so a second
booster to stave off any new wave of
covid apparently
elon musk is challenging
the other alpha cuck
putin
to a duel or something i'm not sure what
the [ __ ] i don't know if he wants to
have like an mma fight with this guy or
something you know i did
alpha cuck versus
alpha cuck really
is what it would be putin versus elon
musk really
i don't know we could probably sell a
lot of [ __ ]
uh pay-per-view tickets for that son of
a [ __ ] maybe pay off the national debt
yeah saying
you know all that could go towards the
national debt
fine by me fight to the death
i'm just saying i don't know if we do
that anymore
in a duel and not what you did in a duel
in the old days you
you fought till someone died i mean you
shoot each other right
i don't know
just snowballing ideas here uh hashtag
planes for ukraine is trending
uh the ukraine want migs they also want
a no fly zone so we'll get into that
we'll get into that
when we go to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
of the day well let's go uh you know
what let's just let's start the
countdown
and let's just see what's in the what's
in the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the [ __ ] list
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends oh
today
we're going to start on the timeline
there's a lot of good stuff going on on
the timeline now there's a lot of good
videos let's make this bigger see all
y'alls y'alls can see y'alls can see
yeah we got a lot of stuff going on here
patriot takes had this posted um an
unearthed madison cough cothorn called
into the charlie kirk show during the
january 6 attack
he said he would use his wheelchair to
transport multiple weapons
ahead of the capitol riot and arm those
who were around him i don't know what
the i don't
it's really confusing let's listen to
the uh let's listen to this [ __ ] and
then we'll [ __ ] talk about it on the
other side so we have congress and
madison cawthon on the line is that
right
yep there we go uh charles madison how
are you congressmen are uh
i wish this was under better
circumstances first of all are you safe
charlie i'm safe yes as you know i uh i
believe in second amendment as well as a
lot of other members so we are armed
we're in safe location we can't disclose
where but uh and that congressman to
your best um i love okay first off
before we
go any further before we go any [ __ ]
further here i want to just say here's
what i want to say i want to say
that when you are talking about how
you're armed and you're safe from the
insurrection right this is on january 6
remember this on january 6 they planned
this [ __ ] we all know that these [ __ ]
seditious traders playing this [ __ ]
but when you when charlie kirk calls and
uh
congressman congress congress boy is
what it should be congress boy
but when charlie kirk calls and and
talks to madison cawthorne on january 6
and madison gothard says we're safe
meaning safe from the [ __ ]
insurrectionist
the bad guys the bad guys right the bad
guys
so if you're the good guy with the gun
who's the bad guy madison cawthorn you
piece of [ __ ] calling you congressman by
the way the youngest ever elected
congressman in american history and uh
madison i do have to say thanks to you
and lo and lauren bobert you guys are
armed now right that's a new thing so
yes indeed yes indeed so you know
obviously having the wheelchair i'm able
to carry many multiple weapons at one
time so i'm able to carry multiple
weapons at one time what the [ __ ] what i
don't understand what he's trying to say
i guess he's trying to say he would pile
weapons on his lap as if madison gotham
runs around with [ __ ] firearms piled
on his lap or something or does he stuff
him up his ass and then sit in the chair
i'm not sure what he's talking about
i don't know if he thinks this is a wild
[ __ ] west and he's got some kind of
[ __ ] uh rifle holder on the side i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about here
i think he's full of [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what i think i think all these
[ __ ] on the screen charlie kirk
and anyone at his show and lauren bobert
especially are all full [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] cosplaying you
little pieces of [ __ ] you goddamn
american taliban you know everyone
around me is armed and you know i think
an armed society is a flight society so
i feel very safe we don't have any high
nerves here everybody's very an arm
society is a polite society that's what
a fascist would say
that's
what a fascist would say
is oh as long as they're scared of me
the others are scared of me i'm in good
shape because otherwise i would be
[ __ ] weak uh rachel makes a good
point here this morning um you guys know
we have rachel bitkoffer on all the time
and and hopefully rachel come on this
week
rachel if you're out there
invitation's open text me call me dm me
come on the show this week maybe we'll
get her on tomorrow wednesday something
like that
rachel says
she she had a trip to texas maybe we'll
talk to her about that the reason the
working class
has the perception that these democrats
are elitist
who don't care despite all their policy
gains from the ds so in other words
the working class the generic ballot
that she's always talking about
that rachel's always talking about has
the perception that democrat are elitist
even though that democrats
give the policy gains for the working
class for the generic ballot they're the
ones that deliver democrats deliver
the policy gains for the working class
or the generic ballot
and the reason why this is that that
they think
dems are elitist
is because the republican party hammers
that message every mother [ __ ]
day
she says we're so weak
we stockholm syndrome their attacks
none of their feels came organically
it's all [ __ ] right it's all [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's always been [ __ ] always will be
[ __ ]
so keep that message pumping that's what
me and rachel try to do that's what i
try to do every single day that's why
i'm on here every day noon eastern 11
central to beat the hell out of the
microphone
to keep the message going to keep
pounding
to keep [ __ ] with these people
he's fascist
that's the key that's the goal yeah
fascist out there
this machine
this machine right here this microphone
this machine that i'm talking into it
kills fascists
that's right
okay thank you rachel
for the messaging
oh here's a here's a good one um 50
shades away had this posted and joe
rogan
is so utterly out of touch he doesn't
understand why ted cruz running for
running to cancun during a snowstorm is
wrong
i'm not sure who this [ __ ] is some i
don't know this guy's from texas i guess
i think he i think he's a comedian or
something i don't know who knows
listen to what joe rogan says here to
this [ __ ] when he starts talking
about ted cruz
running off to cancun listen to what
[ __ ] joe rogan says because here's
the thing folks here's the thing joe
rogan definitely would have packed his
[ __ ] and went to cancun
when the [ __ ] happened in texas listen
to this [ __ ] on ted cruz a lot did you
y'all dude him going to cancun as a
texan that pissed me off so much because
the whole ethos of texas to stay and
fight that's the alamo yeah so when he
ran i was like that's the least texan
[ __ ] ever [ __ ] that but what are you
supposed to do when your power's out and
you have uh you have the money to go to
cancun help the people if you could go
to cancun i'd go jamie could go to
cancun yeah you're not politicians ah
yeah it's okay it's okay when everyone
else runs because it's not like joe
rogan could do anything joe rogan has no
power what see that's the [ __ ]
stupid-ass narrative here that's the
[ __ ] that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing
i've ever heard and that's the shittiest
part about joe rogan his self-narrative
that he's dumb and he's stupid and
there's no power he has over anybody
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
like joe rogan
who lives in texas now
couldn't [ __ ] open up his microphone
open up his social media and lend a hand
to not just democrats and republicans
but everyone in texas during a crisis
and here he is laughing it off hahaha i
would go to cancun guess what
joe rogan is ted cruz ted cruz is joe
rogan
they're one in the [ __ ] same
they hide behind all all kinds of
[ __ ] to act like there's something
they're not
you're not [ __ ] whatever he is a
senator whatever he is help people how
how [ __ ] pathetic is this by the way
they know ted cruz is a piece of [ __ ] i
know he's a piece of [ __ ] but they don't
even know he's a united states senator
for [ __ ] sake or what even a [ __ ]
senator is
it's getting ridiculous in this country
that's the problem
stay there fight help people i see what
you're saying but i also see like you're
not going to do any good you wouldn't
leave your dog thoughts out
that's a shitty thing to do bro yeah i
can't hey take tip
let your [ __ ] dog get your house
dying but there's someone watching his
dog i'm probably not looking out the
window starving to death
[Laughter]
so so [ __ ] funny joe
so [ __ ] funny
all right
let's move on
um russell brand was trending earlier
too apparently the po the
post-millennial you guys know this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] stupid fascist rag
this post-millennial social media why
don't they ban that [ __ ] it's the andy
nobe [ __ ] right the andy no fascist [ __ ]
these [ __ ] nazis
apparently they boosted a video russell
brand i'm not going to play it because
he's a dumb [ __ ]
russell brand is comparing the ottawa
truckers to
to ukrainians fighting for their
democracy what a [ __ ] idiot russell
brand you are such a dumb [ __ ] how did
your mind turn to such much
jesus [ __ ] christ
russell brand comparing the ottawa
truckers convoy
to ukrainians fighting and dying for
their democracy for their even even
their corrupt flimsy democracy they're
still fighting for it that's the whole
point
that's the whole [ __ ] point is
that even even a flimsy corrupt
democracy is worth fighting for because
it's better than the alternative
authoritarianism
that's how that's how
ukrainians would rather have their
corrupt democracy than the authoritarian
putin
you [ __ ]
i said this over the weekend it's well
past time
to start offending the appropriate
people [ __ ] them
it is time we start offending these
[ __ ] i don't know if you've
seen some of these [ __ ] bills
boy they're really going hard fast and
hard after women they're going fast and
hard after liberty missouri is trying to
pass a bill where a woman it's against
the law for her to leave the state to
get a medical procedure
in texas apparently in texas
they want to make it to where the death
penalty is on the table
for a woman who receives a medical
procedure
hard and fast i've been saying for
[ __ ] weeks the anti-gay anti-trans
anti-woman take your [ __ ] liberty
away bills is a slow march to [ __ ]
executions
it's a slow march to gas chambers don't
[ __ ] believe me
they're already talking about it in
texas
how they might give someone the death
penalty for having a certain medical
procedure
because the woman chose her life
it's it's creeping there folks
it's creeping there
this video was posted
of lindsey graham i think it's worth
replaying here i actually posted on tic
tac let's watch this video
if you can't admire joe biden as a
person that's probably you've got a
problem
you need to do some self-evaluation
because what's not to like
here's what i can tell you
that life can change just like that yeah
i can it sure can lindsay
you can you can turn on a dime when you
go golfing with the cheeto dust mobster
and he reveals that there's all kinds of
of compromising information he could
release on you
and then you uh you become a syca fan
just like that boom just like that your
life changes just like that lindsay
don't take relationships for granted i
called him after bo
died
and he basically said well
bo was my soul
i've talked for a long time
he came to my ceremony
uh and said some of the most
incredibly heartfelt things that anybody
could ever say to me yeah and uh
he's a human being
the nicest person that he's ever met in
politics
think about this think how many people
lindsey graham has quote unquote met
in politics
and joe biden he says here is the nicest
is that right
he is as good a man as god ever created
i don't agree on much
but i think he's
been dealt a really good blow
i think of course this is after
joe biden's son beau biden
died from cancer
as you know
during the state of the union address
when the president united states joe
biden
brought up how beau biden had died from
cancer
lindsey graham entered the picture
because lauren bobert had shouted out
some [ __ ] vile [ __ ]
about not only soldiers but over top of
joe biden talking about his son passing
away from cancer and lindsey graham
it looked like he said oh [ __ ]
yeah
uh ron posted this uh video of uh booger
sugar junior
um this [ __ ] rant about gasoline
let's let's take a look at what what
what booger sugar junior don jr
has to say about gastric you gotta look
at it this is [ __ ] crazy this guy
look at this look at see the [ __ ]
logo here look at this logo here
what is that
what the [ __ ] i don't know i think it
looks like [ __ ]
i mean i'm no design expert but that
looks like [ __ ] let's listen to what
this [ __ ] idiot has to say
so the leading
the world's leading state sponsor of
terror will take their oil and gas we
won't deal with texas we won't deal with
pennsylvania what is he talking about we
won't deal with texas or pennsylvania
what is he talking about
but states don't [ __ ] sell oil
what is he talking about states
states don't sell oil
that's not how it works
number one we won't deal with other so
they show this graph and then
you have gensake and the board you know
the media narrative machine they're
running out there on tv the board what
is this some kind of new thing that
they're talking about this this new
language they're saying
right
yeah yeah yeah this is all ukraine and
this is all putin's fault
what they don't show you is they don't
show you a chart of what happened to gas
prices over the year prior to any of us
hearing about knowing about
understanding a problem in ukraine
they're trying to say that all of those
problems
were caused by russia
oh [ __ ] this guy he thinks joe biden
invented gas prices like gasoline and
gas prices just started just when joe
biden became president like there was no
price history
that we couldn't [ __ ] figure out how
gas prices worked there was nothing in
it prior to january 20th 2021 of gas
prices and pricing history and the
market history and the market evaluation
of gasoline
what in the [ __ ] is right
number one the reason why gasoline was
so goddamn low when joe biden took
office is because the economy was in the
[ __ ] dumps
it was in the [ __ ] dumps
no one no one was we came out of a
[ __ ] depression
of people using gasoline you dumb [ __ ]
oil had tanked
people were were
giving people money to take oil
no one was driving
there was a pandemic
it really it really is [ __ ]
boneheaded type [ __ ] that he thinks i
like this look on him by the way where i
pause it i think i may leave it there uh
look
look [ __ ]
the reason why gas prices went up after
joe biden became president that first
year is because it's called supply and
demand and there's other factors like
opec
starving off supply so that there is
created a
false demand the other thing too is no
one is saying it's all putin's fault
i mean the war in ukraine is putin's
fault which has caused us to have to
sanction the [ __ ] and tell him
to take his oil and shove it up his
[ __ ] ass
that's putin's fault
so that hurts our supply for the time
being
until we can either drill more here or
buy more somewhere else
to get the supply
in the meantime we have the oil
companies with record [ __ ] profits
gouging every single person
and it's not joe biden
fault you dumb [ __ ]
it's not like only american only
american gasoline is rising all around
the world is plummeting in prices joe
biden though he's pushing the gasoline
button on his desk he's turning up the
gasoline prices because that's how it
[ __ ] work get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
all because some dumb [ __ ] seen
a sticker on a gas pump that said joe
biden did that
how do they believe this crackhead
really honestly how do they do it
a little less coke there donnie a little
less coke
oh oh i want to remind you
if you're not following me on instagram
then get over there and help me figure
it out i don't i need lessons over on
instagram we're on instagram now i'm on
instagram i have been but i just i just
started posting over there
so go over there and just go to
thetonymichaels.com go to the link in my
bio you can follow the instagram follow
me on instagram also follow me on tik
tok if you're over on tick tock as well
[Music]
we've got
gabe posted here
i don't know if you've seen this we had
a a great video series over the weekend
we worked with uh jojo from jurors
uh she had written some tweets and we
decided to do a
a video series off the tweets it's
fantastic um we may we just may play the
first one in the commercial break today
so stay tuned for that um we'll probably
get to play those in the commercial
breaks they're there
they're there
okay uh
here is uh i'm gonna play one shot
from uh this weekend aaron had posted
this video
uh putin's i said putin's grip is tight
on donald trump
listen to what this [ __ ] fascist says
listen to what he says we will pass
critical reforms making every executive
branch employee fireable
fireable by the president of the united
states the deep state must and will be
brought to heal it's already happening
we will pass critical re okay
so first off here
i'm not exactly opposed to this
i'm not exactly opposed to joe biden
being able to fire
uh louis de joy are you i mean i i
honestly
i think that check and balance can go
[ __ ] that check and balance
but honestly this is coming this is
coming from a position
of a putin-style dictorial ship
right dictatorship sorry
he wants to be kim jong-un he wants to
be vladimir putin vladimir putin bans
the word war
kim jong-un murders and kills any
dissident so does putin
and that's what he means he doesn't
actually mean oh i want to fire him
they don't actually mean i just want to
stop a woman from having abortion what
they mean is i want to get rid of that
person
i don't want to stop someone from being
gay i don't want to stop someone from
being trans i want to get rid of their
existence are you listening
this is what fascism
does
it is on our front doorstep
we shall not let it go through the back
door
we have to call this out we have to show
this for what it is all america needs to
know what the because all americans
aren't watching this [ __ ]
they're not listening to the voices that
need to be listened to jesus christ the
entire world burnt down when tom brady
retired and the entire world burnt down
again when he said i'm not retiring
that was the [ __ ] news
every american knows that news
no one knows that the former president
united states not only is his company
his private [ __ ] company is under
criminal and civil indictment
members members of his [ __ ] cabinet
are under investigation members
members of the group that is one step
away from him have pled guilty
to conspiracy to sedition an oath keeper
who was roger stone's private bodyguard
on january 6 when he tried to take over
the government and attempt a cheeto dust
kangaroo gu
one step away you don't think roger
stone was on the phone with donald trump
you don't think roger stone is one step
away
from the cheeto dust mobster
but america doesn't know
america has no idea that he stole
classified documents
america has no idea that he was putting
doc
top secret documents in burn bags and
flushing them down the toilet
eating our he was eating are you
listening he was eating
our [ __ ] records of the office of the
president of the united states our the
american people those are our records he
was eating them like they were [ __ ] a
big mac
because he needed to hide what they said
yep
america doesn't know yet
we have to show them
we have to tell them
we have to tell everyone around us
at your family barbecue at your
community center your churches your
schools in the [ __ ] grocery line with
the checkout person
stop talking about tom brady who gives a
[ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] if that guy plays
football or not not going to make one
hell of a bit of a difference in our
democracy and frankly
frankly
tom brady with his white pasty ass will
be one of the only quarterbacks that'll
be able to throw a ball once fascism
takes over
mark my words
uh today let's see what else do we have
here
uh
oh you guys heard the story
a bran
brent renault an award-winning american
filmmaker and journalist was killed
on sunday
um
in kiev
the ukrainian authorities they took way
they were under fire
he was wounded there's a video of his
colleague in the hospital
um he was wounded as well he made it out
he lived
um they were able to pull him away from
the mess
i think i have that here yeah let's
let's watch here now this is his
colleague
um
i think his name is juan yeah let's
watch this here tell me tell me please
what is your name
where are you from uh the us yes
what happened to uh we were across one
the first bridge and near king
we're going to film other refugees
leaving
and we got into a car somebody offered
to take us to the other bridge
and we crossed a checkpoint and they
start shooting at us
so the driver turned around and they
kept shooting it's two of us my friend's
friend renault
and he's been shot and left behind
and how is he i don't know i don't know
you don't know what happened
i saw his being shot in the neck
and we got split and i got
into the uh
and who brought you here
so there you see it he was in the
hospital uh being treated for gunshot
wounds as he uh talked about his friend
uh being
taken under fire
and
not being able to be
pulled
from the
fight um
and
they confirmed that brent
had died suffered his wounds this is a
real war over there like this isn't fake
ass [ __ ] this isn't [ __ ] fake ass
convoy type [ __ ]
not fake ass fighting for your freedom
of mandates that don't exist
of driving around in your [ __ ]
loaded up ga your gas guzzling trucks to
to protest gas prices
none of that fake ass patriot [ __ ]
none of the fake ass freedom [ __ ]
nope
it's real [ __ ] people in ukraine
fighting for their actually fighting for
their democracy against an authoritarian
which if we're not careful and we let
these [ __ ] idiots like the trucker
convoy
morons take over this country
don't think don't think don't think
donald trump wouldn't fire government
officials he said it on stage don't
think he wouldn't fire government
officials and put the people who are in
charge of organizing the trucker convoy
in charge of our government don't put it
past him i'm telling you don't
he'll do it he have to he'll have to who
else will [ __ ] work for him he'll
hack the [ __ ] half his administration
from the last one has wrote a book about
how [ __ ] terrible that [ __ ]
is they held all the information to
write books
what you're going to talk about in an
interview this week and an answer from
someone nip
let's see what else do we have here
um
oh yes yes speaking of fascist
morons
let's let's take a look this is a guy at
the trump rally this week in the same
rally where he said that he he should
execute i mean fire
not execute sorry
he didn't say that yet his fire
government officials
whenever and wherever he wants for
whatever reason
just for being dissidents let's listen
to this [ __ ]
i try to get on the plane i'll have to
i'll have to punch out the the
stewardess because i'm not going to wear
a mask they're not going to make me
they'll have to and i'm definitely not
getting back today
you might die first uh gabe's joining us
here gabe did you hear that did you hear
this uh knucklehead here at the trump
rally yeah and i heard kobet say all
right bet
hold my [ __ ] beer huh yeah hold my
phone it's like they'll have to kill me
first and it's like literally like
coping and the grim reaper hand in hand
they're like okay yeah cool cool welcome
gabe welcome welcome to the show
everybody welcome gabe um you know this
this really is uh this guy here is kind
of like uh trumpism in 15 seconds right
like oh yeah like here's the thing
i actually because this guy won't get on
a plane because there's a mask mandate
right i actually that is more of a
reason for everyone to be like you know
what we're just gonna sacrifice and
everyone's gonna wear mask on a plane so
dumb [ __ ] like this never get on a
plane again right like the funny the
funny thing is he he's like oh you know
if the stewardess ever does this to me
and i'm like okay one
not called stewardess anymore right
right
but i made a i made a video called uh
maga airlines and i have that as a joke
literally at the end when it's like make
sure to inform your flight attendant i'm
sorry i mean stewardess no if you like
your magazine i forgot what the line is
but uh i have that exact line in there
where
he says the right term and then corrects
himself to be incorrect
and says stewardess instead of uh well
that's because they're totally
predictable though right i mean
again we have such a hard time sometimes
doing satire of these people like
because they're so out in front of us
like we can't even we can't even get out
in front of these [ __ ] like
even the videos we made this weekend
people were commenting and they're like
wait is it is this right some of them
thought it was real yeah like some
people were like oh is this real audio
like you guys did the video or whatever
but like is this from real people right
right and that's where we are right now
where most people are like i don't it
sounds so dumb it's so ridiculous
that i've come to accept there's like an
80 chance that it's real you know why i
do i do want to say we are going to play
we are going to play the commercial
um that gabe is talking about today or
excuse me the video during the
commercial break um
here in just a bit um of of the video
that gabe's talking about where it's
called letters
uh of the trucker convoy and uh jojo
from jurors wrote a tweet i i i had this
vision in my head when i seen the tweet
and uh i proposed to her that we should
do
um these these letters in a video and it
it worked out perfect yeah and every
everyone really likes them because they
they are hilarious
yeah yeah yeah but the thing is is you
could
you could actually see them saying these
things oh hands down yeah i mean you
look at this guy right here and he's a
walking parody like just just the
embodiment of trumpism it's the same
thing whenever i see people who are like
uh
i don't i know a bunch of republicans
and none of them say that you know or
they're like uh i'm republican and i've
literally never said that and i'm like
whether that's true or not uh the fact
of the matter is that these people exist
and then what's hilarious is those
people say
uh
that it's not in fact
uh something that's said but then they
double down and then validate the
character
by saying the like almost they can
almost as if they continue the the
conversation
of what that character that i had
would continue to say
and i'm like you
you denied that
it's like when i made a video about uh
republicans on halloween and all the
things that they would say to
trick-or-treaters like oh socialism free
candy and all this stuff like gotta work
for it like you know put yourself about
bootstraps and go up in the tree
and people were like oh
i've never heard someone say that and
then they double down and then say
something that sounds so dumb
as if it was the republican handing out
candy or rather not handing out candy on
halloween
and i'm like well thank you very much
for just you know further validating the
character that i'm i'm i based this on
so
it it is it again it is hard to satire
these idiots right here's another
example right here
the over the weekend ron desantis let me
take the banner down so we can see so
the people on the screen can see this
but over over the uh the weekend ron
desantis calls disney woke
what the [ __ ] does this even mean
anymore like they literally have watered
down the word woke so much like what are
we like last week we were talking about
like if joe biden is sleepy biden and
he's woke biting right like it's two
different things like what do you mean
by woke right and also all of the people
who are always like oh you got to get
awake you got to see what's going on you
got to open your eyes you know it's like
so if i'm awake i would be woke right
right right right you know it's it's so
dumb and the thing is like you know we
talked about woke sky and they just
throw woken and this and that like as if
it's a bad thing where it's like oh god
forbid i wanted to care for another
human being or like i want to respect
what their uh what their
whatever with their lifestyle their way
of living
their choices like you say my body my
choice you should in fact respect those
choices of another person and what they
do with their body or with their lives
right it's not actually affecting you or
hurting your your your body
so shut the [ __ ] up well i i mean this
goes back to what i was saying earlier
is these these [ __ ] are you know they
they they doing this messaging [ __ ] you
know like the pro-life thing but here
they are trying to pass laws in states
texas apparently someone's floated an
idea
that they want to make a medical
procedure that a woman would have
punishable by the death penalty
think about this pro-lifers are so
pro-life they're so [ __ ] pro-life
that they want to make sure that if a
woman makes the choice to save her own
life with an eptopic pregnancy that they
just might kill her i i i can't even you
can't even [ __ ] start i think it's
most people i bet you if you ask them
what that was they would be like oh yeah
it's a pregnancy when in fact it's just
the it's it's a it
it's right well it has the word
pregnancy in it right right yeah but you
look at it and it's like okay if i were
to you know like
stop someone on the street and say hey
do you know what an ectopic pregnancy is
they'd be like uh pregnancy and you're
like well what if someone wanted to
abort that ectopic pregnancy and you're
like yeah that's bad right that's what
they would say but really it's like oh
[ __ ] this person could die because it's
actually a practice that's happening
not where it should be
so it's just
i i mean well you're not you're not
gonna get you're not
it sucks to suck it really does sucks to
suck and and their ideas suck they know
they suck so what they're trying to do
is gather up as much [ __ ] crazy ass
support on the internet that they can
here
and they're trying to be as loud as they
possibly can uh here's another example
of it right here speaking of texas and
and non-pro life pro lifers ted cruz
here's a press conference and listen to
what one of the truckers in the thing
yells out
you look at the origins
uh of the pandemic
the virus
ted cruz sucks i mean there's no more
truth than you can even tell wait can
you open that back up
i want to point something out to the
audience
uh see this guy in the red
black checkered shirt here so this guy
over here yeah yeah his name is brian
brace or brian
tell us about brian
brian
uh
a few days ago
called in
uh one of the people that called in to
911.
okay so so so wait a second you're
talking about at the trucker convoy yeah
yeah on at the trucker convoy there was
some there was an an incident or
multiple incidents right where people
were driving by the truckers and they
were
they were as he said
throwing the bird there were birds
flying everywhere oh boys were flying
were they tweeting were they tweeting
because no it wasn't okay i've actually
got a video uh coming out today about
did did they have did they release the
dubs i'm not sure what it wasn't dove's
they weren't throwing it he was like you
know throwing a big bird at him you know
nothing like that it was
as in throwing a bird like flipping you
off so he calls into nine one oh the
middle finger right middle finger
mj says here fat wolverine does suck oh
yeah with a super chat thank you mj
thank you
uh but brian over here uh is
you know a guy who wants to he's a
champion of freedom
free speech and
all things liberty right and then no
mandates no mail dates no mandates woman
dates you know right and uh
and
i feel like we're getting a sneak
preview of the video already
i didn't i i did not put that in there
didn't i put that in maybe maybe maybe
maybe i should slide in no mandates only
woman
woman dates are the only thing women
women can't throw the finger men you
know what that might be i might have to
do a second video now maybe it's a part
two maybe yeah i mean they it's the same
same same as the uh the letters it's
just constant
just uh material but anyway brian here
calls into 911 did did an interview and
complained about how these people up
there were so mean and no one
from from once they started
the convoy was ever that mean no one was
flipping them off
and so he calls in and he tells everyone
because he's also an organizer he's one
of the guys who started this whole thing
in the u.s and he complained and said
you should flood 9-1-1 and we should get
them to tell uh all of these people on
the road wait wait wait so he called 9-1
or he encouraged everyone to call nine
uh i believe he called on both but also
encouraged others to flood 9-1-1
meanwhile the
state is like please don't do that do
not do that flipping someone off is not
an emergency not an emergency uh i'm
sorry that your feelings were hurt
because somebody in their own car
decided to [ __ ] throw you the bird
and you were all upset in your big old
boy truck you know and honk your horn
and fighting for freedom and all of a
sudden as soon as someone just throws
something so just
slight like this as you drive by they go
that's mean gabe don't do that that is
mean
i'm the victim
that is exactly what's happening so
that's brian ryan is a big snowflake uh
and he is melting and this guy's in big
as in uh snow flaky big or he's just
like six foot two six with three i don't
know how tall he is because i don't know
how
fat wolverine is so it's hard to get a
perspective but what i will say is
uh he's just a a bigly baby you know
right well
is he is this the same guy because i'm
not sure these these two guys on the
flanking um um the snow lizard here
that's what i call takers the snow
lizard i like fat wolverine yeah yeah
but snow lizard you know that that's my
nickname for him so the flanking the
snow lizard here isn't one of these guys
is it brian that had the little that had
the stage set up the weekend before last
week was that who it was yeah yeah
so he was like the only one that him in
like 20 media oh oh that one uh
that's that good question i would have
let me look it up really quick
i mean i mean it looks i i mean i can't
tell because you know um from the video
that i think you posted um or that you
shared i believe of the rally or the or
the little where he had the stage right
like i think his family was there maybe
a few of his yeah the ratio was like 30
to one it was like right 30 reporters
and one of him right right uh
but yeah he
i'm not sure if that's the guy i'm not
sure
yeah all i know is that this guy is the
one that's behind organizing the the
uh people's convoy
and
uh
he's the biggest baby because he was
like well i didn't get what i wanted or
like they were calling 911
for people who have not uh traveled in a
[ __ ] semi truck before that [ __ ] is
loud okay right you got you you are
above people so you would have to be
actively looking down
at the car next to you to see someone
flip you off and even if someone flipped
you off in front of you it'd be like
whatever you know some no big deal that
is their freedom of speech the thing you
are in fact
fighting for right right well that's
what they say right exactly but remember
freedom of speech
until i feel uncomfortable and then you
got to shut the [ __ ] up speaking of semi
trucks and riding in semi trucks let me
see if i can
um grab
there was a guy
um yeah here it is there was a guy who
who tried to climb out of a semi truck i
don't know if you've seen this oh yeah
um let's see let's see i think yeah i
got it here okay this this is this is a
semi truck that maybe a certain um
snow lizard or someone who would run
away from texas when it got you know a
little cold to cancun
this is how he got out of us i wonder
how he got in i wonder if there's video
of that but this is how i think i think
i've seen a video of him getting in did
it take like three or four people to get
him up in there because it really
they weren't sure if he was gonna get
out because when he gets out you'll see
what they do watch this okay
oh hey
don't grab that one uh where's my foot
oh
the thing is that this it's only like
three and a half four feet and there's
steps there so you could just
jump down yeah you did it
just keep just keep playing and listen
to what he says next
are you ready
good to be back he says good there's
brian by the way there's oh yeah
yeah let's let's let's the
there's brian was he driving no he
wasn't driving the truck i don't know i
mean he's a trucker he might have been
driving i'm not sure he is he is a
trucker yeah that is converter but ted
cruz comes back and i even said i made a
tweet about this i like ted cruz [ __ ]
struggles to get off this truck he sits
down you know he's zipping up his jacket
and says
good to be back like
from what the guy had just like it's as
if the guy just come back from a tour of
duty and in a war and he was like good
to be back i'd only been gone for 24
hours if that well he was gone for 12
minutes he got the truck drove down the
street got out of the truck i mean
there's canoe trips longer than what ted
cruz was in this truck well here here
here's here's the here's a picture of
this [ __ ] idiot inside the truck here
[Music]
number one if ted cruz was so cool if
ted cruz was really so cool which he's
not he's not even close to being cool
not even close if he was so cool he
would just he would have drove the semi
truck
like that's right if he was really cool
which also here's the thing i mean semi
trucks uh you know
they're not easy
a lot of shifting gears you know it
takes you know it takes it it's a skill
for sure uh
uh but i would also say that some of
those people driving those trucks
probably aren't
the brightest and i say that because of
what we're seeing right now we're
fighting over the dumbest things that
are no longer i mean what are what are
they there for really honestly well they
said that they're fighting freedom right
they're they're they're a champion
they're fighting freedom or for freedom
they're a champion for free speech in
all things liberty right other than the
middle finger that right exactly yeah
yeah yeah uh there are perceptions
they're like oh if if if a woman throws
me in the middle finger oh no uh my
world has just fallen apart right um but
because remember it it originally
started with hey we want to fight him
against these mandates and then they're
like
okay
uh
which mandates because because there is
there are no mandates like there's no
right right well there's it was the
vaccine mandates because the truckers
are like oh you know to get back into
canada or to go into the u.s and you
know we need a vaccine uh
but the truckers here but the truckers
here in this country don't have mandates
it was just a mandate to in to enter
no mandates in here so it's the whole
thing of like there are it's like oh
vaccine mandates and mask mandates it's
again it's like you're in the truck for
hours on end you have literally
literally like little interaction with
anyone
until you get to like wherever the
loading dock is or wherever you drop off
the
the uh the delivery so there's not a lot
of interaction and there's not a lot of
issue with like you know
spreading unless you're like
sleeping in the in the in the bed of the
truck with with right a bunch of people
but
it's the they they fight the mandates
and so then everyone's like well the
mandates are going away like what are
you doing you know and they're like well
we gotta we and i did it in a video
which debate all of their arguments
which again everyone comes after and not
everyone but a bunch of republicans came
after me like oh this is not this is a
straw this is a [ __ ] uh a straw man
fallacy argument you know what i'm like
no it's not and if you do believe it is
then please present the arguments that
are there and everyone has shut the [ __ ]
up so basically gabe we know that you
get paid by soros to make these
arguments i mean listen listen every
video is a million bucks
i mean that's that that's how this show
continues is right it's george soro i
mean we haven't gotten our check yet but
i mean it's in the mail but it's kind of
held up by like the convoy you know
because they're like part of the
delivery so you know right i'm sure
it'll be here next week but it's that
it's it's them saying oh we want to
fight mandates well the mandates are
going away so what are you guys really
fighting well we want to fight the fact
that there's high gas prices like okay
well then maybe you should talk to opec
i don't know or not be driving wasting
gas right exactly why are you burning
gas and diesel around the beltway you're
only okay one you're just uh furthering
uh to climate change you're you're
you're disrupting the lives of dc
residents who actually rely on the
beltway so you're actually uh
you're a hindrance you're um
you're an annoyance
to uh many people within that
that uh that that area and then the
other part is then they're like well you
know what you know what people will
listen to us if we shut everything down
and it's like okay fine so you want to
shut everything down by not delivering
you want to say hey you know what those
shelves that we complained about that
weren't actually stocked but it really
wasn't the problem we're actually going
to make sure that they actually want to
have that problem yeah
this is the this is this is the the plan
is to create chaos and then blame it on
because everything's joe biden's fault
right exactly i mean it's it's all joe
biden's well i mean thanks brandon um
here is uh this is this is quite
humorous so the video that we were just
watching
and i'm not gonna play it again but but
uh nope yeah maybe
if my zoom works here ted cruz actually
thought it was a good idea to post that
video he said thank you to every trucker
who is standing up for freedom for every
man woman and child in america what the
what freedom i don't know
i don't know i freed them to what to to
to have traffic on a highway i mean
literally these people were not stopped
there was nothing there was nothing done
to stop these people
no one no no law enforcement agency
prevented them from driving around the
beltway um the only people that tried to
stop anything from happening is brian
there called 9-1-1 to try to get try to
get those
those whim dates those women dates done
so they didn't give us the middle finger
we don't want them to give us the middle
finger which i think we might have a
video about but
um that you released yesterday if anyone
wants to go go to gabe's timeline you
can see the uh
the and we'll maybe we'll play him in
the second hour here but that the
trucker convoys from letter that joe
helped us with ted your [ __ ] tweet
sucks
it [ __ ] sucks don't post the video
that makes you look like an idiot on
your own timeline not a good idea um so
let's see i think there was one other
video though that i wanted to show of
ted cruz here about the trucker convo
maybe not oh yes because it was it's
what he says when he gets out of the
truck right because he says some dumb
[ __ ] not just him exiting but what does
he say that's when he gets that was the
thing i was saying when he gets when he
gets out he goes glad to be back or good
to be back
right but he says he says something else
he answers some questions i think he
says something else oh let's see if we
can ted cruz trucker ooh that
that feels gross to even type in
uh
here it has chinese symbols that's
appropriate uh is this that's not when
he gets out
there's get here's him get in oh here we
go here we go here we go everybody we
only caught that we only caught like the
second half of it so we don't know if he
struggled he went the same way he went
back up the same way as he went down
all right so
maybe maybe maybe well maybe let's see
where you made it up there woohoo you
got in the truck yeah success the fact
also that a sitting u.s president said
yeah i'm gonna skip work today and i'm
gonna go for a joyride because i'm gonna
do something that is all just not
president senator don't give him that
much credit
you said president no i said i said
president i think you said president i
said i thought i said sitting senator i
think i think you said sitting president
sorry did not mean that that was gross
and so there's the press conference
again where he says he's like maybe i
don't have the video all right well
let's let's do this let's go to the
commercial uh pay attention to the
commercial break here and you'll see the
video and then when we come back we'll
we'll play the the round to the part two
of the letters from trucker's convoy
stay with us right after the break we'll
be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out of natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
oh bob and tammy bob and tammy tammy and
bob
letters from the trucker convoy
[Music]
i hope bob does uh decide to wipe his
ass at least once a day
i mean
theoretically i guess i guess if you poo
one today you're going to wipe your ass
once a day but that's not you know in
theory i guess maybe yeah
i also i'm also like uh
i kind of i joked about this this
weekend i was like oh bob and tammy not
to be confused with the hulu show pam
and tommy right right you know very
different but probably very interesting
lives in some way you know it it it
could probably be a reality show i don't
know hands down a lot of people were
saying that we should do a series yeah
and speaking of doing a series here is
part two
of letters from the truckers convoy here
let's um
let's play this here
letters from the trucker convoy
part two
dears tammy today was a dark day
there i was
minding my own business cruising around
the beltway
went up come a mess of young girls
and they done gave me the middle finger
it
it was real mean like
now i'm scared
send nudes
dear bob
don't let them comment live girls that
flipped you off get y'all upset
remember why you're there you're there
cuz
well
i don't really know why you're there but
don't you lose sight of it
whatever
it is
well here's a pic of my tits
sorry about the rash
stay strong
here's
tammy
[Applause]
oh my god
i i can't help yeah um just to give the
audience uh the lowdown on these videos
what happened was is joe uh these are
documentary these pbs [ __ ] ken burns
[ __ ] right
well so joe jojo from jurors wrote a
tweet and it was the very first one the
letter to tammy right and and like as
soon as i read it i heard that in my
brain and i'm like oh god we got to do
like a a ken burns letter from trucker
convoy and then she wrote the follow-up
from tammy to bob and i'm like oh now we
got to definitely do it so we recorded
me and joe recorded our voices with the
letters we sent that to gabe and gabe
made the videos so it was a call because
it was like it was some it was
i had i was like i had woken up and i
was like doing some stuff and i get a
message and you were like hey can we do
this and i was like yeah we could do
anything whatever yeah right why not why
not
and so so not only did we er so
so joe kept writing these things so
there may or may not be
part three part four i mean i don't know
how long some people were like
i mean i'm just saying it seems like
there's a saga like it's gonna there's
gonna be a lot right and i feel like
this is one of those things where
people might be like oh god i hate these
people but i'm growing to
i'm growing i'm going to like them right
because they seem they're like well
these are like real people with real
problems you know
right but at the same time i mean the
rash you know yeah yeah
he hasn't had a rat who hasn't been
right
with their cousin you know right i mean
brody who everyone has a brody right
everyone's got a brody everyone's got a
broom adam adrian it's whatever you know
it's
everyone's got one and at the end of the
day uh there may be
five there might be 35 i don't know you
know it's kind of great you can tell who
can tell who can tell so may so maybe
we'll do uh
maybe even maybe in this afternoon there
might be a part three tomorrow i i don't
know keep keep an eye out for
for uh bob and tammy the uh the saga of
bob and tammy i hear you might have to
go gabe
so so uh good luck with that work today
and uh i'll send over anything to be
made yeah yeah videos later on yeah look
out everyone else
say bye to gabe everyone have a good one
gabe
we'll talk to you soon
all right let's get back to the shitless
roundup uh oh where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends of
the day
oh man bob and tammy bob
and tammy okay let's go to the the
trends uh dolly parton is trending
i like to focus on dolly here not that
it has to do with politics but dolly is
like one of the best human beings in the
world dolly parton is seeking to take
herself out of the contention for the
rock and roll hall of fame saying i
don't feel like i have earned that right
she was among 17 genre spanning nominees
this year
so dolly partner parton
taking herself out of the running
because she is a decent human being who
thinks that she should not be in the
running so she doesn't want to be in the
running
thank you dolly for being a decent human
being i think everyone thanks you
okay um i this isn't uh politics or on
the list but scott hall
the former wrestler
is on life support i'm not i'm not sure
um
tmz sports here saying wwe legend kevin
nash announced scott hall's family would
discontinue his life support on monday
uh so we may have news today if if it
hasn't already happened if he can't live
without life support
if uh scott hall
or um
razer raymond as he was also known
would uh
uh pass away he was he was one of the
good bad guys
you know i always say we're at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life and we really are
and uh
scott hall's career
as the bad guy as everyone liking the
bad guy doesn't illustrate that better
like he he was he was pre
stone cold steve austin where the bad
guy was cool um when he was razor
raymond so
you know scott hall
good heart
great great wrestler great career
um did a wonderful job
pretending to be the bad guy it's just
too bad that people
couldn't catch on that he wasn't
actually the bad guy okay let's move on
here uh
elon musk is in the news
oh my god
you can't you really can't make this
[ __ ] up you can't make this [ __ ] up
elon musk has challenged vladimir putin
to single combat for ukraine
what in the actual [ __ ] is going on
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
again this is the whole wrestlemania
real life thing we are at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life where elon musk thinks he can
challenge vladimir putin to a duel or a
single combat as he calls it what the
[ __ ] does that even mean
what does that mean
joe walsh says shut the [ __ ] up elon
musk you're not a serious person now go
take all the money of yours and do
something useful with it like funding
educational scholarship for low-income
youth
not a bad idea joe not a bad idea and
i'm not always a fan of joe walsh i
don't agree with a lot of [ __ ] joe walsh
says everybody
not at all
half the time i would tell joe walsh to
go [ __ ] himself and shut the [ __ ] up
himself but he is correct with elon musk
uh meteorite has the story here i hereby
challenge vladimir putin
here's here
i hereby challenge vladimir putin to
single combat stakes are ukraine
in an absolute serious tweet
so he not only is he saying really
stupid [ __ ] but he's saying it's
absolutely serious that he's gonna you
know i don't know jump in the ring with
him i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
gonna do
what are they gonna do have a thumb war
or something
i don't understand it i don't understand
it i don't get it okay now let's see
what some others have wrote about oh
no that's not it
i would play this video here by but it
would boost the post millennial and they
can go suck one [ __ ] the post millennial
they can eat a big bag of horse dicks
posting this [ __ ] and russell bland
should be ashamed of himself that's
right russell come on the show if you
want
we'll have it out here [ __ ] him um
let's see elon musk is
the biggest douche in the world
he's the biggest douche in the world
isn't he
i mean there's a lot of douchebags but
like he's king douchebag
elon musk
king douchebag
he is uh joe manchin looks like he's in
the news uh for his really bad take on
um electric vehicles i think
yeah brett has it here uh truly the most
mind-numbingly stupid take i've ever
heard about electric cars cars from joe
manchin uh joe manchin says i'm very
reluctant to go down the path of
electric vehicles
joe manchin said i'm old enough to
remember standing in line in 1974
trying to buy gas
okay
what does that have to do with an
electric car i remember those days
i don't want to have to be standing in
line waiting for a battery for my
vehicle
because we're now dependent on foreign
supply chain mostly china what the [ __ ]
is he talking about
this isn't like the remote control joe
mansion
when your battery runs out you don't
switch the batteries dumb [ __ ]
you charge them
what the [ __ ] is he talking about does
he really think that every time the
battery goes dead on an electric vehicle
you switch the batteries like you do the
remote control
what is he talking about
are you catching this i don't i can't
figure this [ __ ] out
he says i'm standing in line waiting for
a battery for my vehicle
no no the battery comes with the vehicle
you just recharge the battery
and you don't necessarily have to stand
in line and normally you charge it at
home
the other thing that's truly
mind-numbing here as brett points out
about the electric vehicles and the
stupid [ __ ] argument
is is the gas price argument right
because this is what he's doing is he's
perpetuating well
those gas prices high but can you
imagine waiting for a battery
what
here's the thing though
is the reason why we are so dependent
on [ __ ] fuel in this country
is because republicans stand in the way
of public infrastructure
and public transit
democrats
are the ones who would deliver
high-speed rail in this country
that that's who
democrats are the ones
who want to
cut
ourselves from fossil fuels
democrats not not republicans you know
they they do the whole climate changing
reel and oh we love oil we love oil i
hate i hate to stand in line for a
battery to change my batteries
as if it's a [ __ ] remote control he
has a cell phone right
joe manchin surely has a [ __ ] cell
phone
he has to have a [ __ ] cell phone
like he plugs that [ __ ] in and
charges it right what does he think's
inside that [ __ ]
he's gotta understand how [ __ ]
batteries work right that that you can
recharge those son of a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is he talking about here
holy [ __ ]
it is it is ridiculously stupid
um and of course everyone's railing him
about this
um about the
the uh and again here he's in the news
for something else i could buy democrats
as breaking senator joe manchin stabs
joe biden in the back again no surprise
announces that he will oppose the
president's nomination for sarah bloom
raskin to the federal reserve board
mikey dooming her chances for
confirmation
oh
more reason for joe manchin to get
people pissed off
so we'll talk about him
so i'm gonna stop talking about it [ __ ]
joe manchin [ __ ] him
robin's got it right democrats deliver
republi because republicans destroy like
that's what they do
so democrats deliver thank you robin
he's trending number 18.
i always get excited when rand paul's
trending because you know it's something
really [ __ ] stupid he said
like and either that either that or if
it's doctor foughty dunking on that
[ __ ]
like just slam dunking on that
[ __ ] please tell me that's what
happened please tell me if ouchie dunked
on him is that why he's trending
someone tell me now
someone please oh is this the thing
where he wants to to appoint uh like a
board of people to replace anthony fauci
and hope in hopes that he can school
them
and not get schooled and not get dunked
on is that his plan here i'm not sure
i mean
essentially rand paul is always trending
because he's a dumb [ __ ]
always he's always trending as he's a
dumb [ __ ] i mean this is not this is not
new news
well let's see
hey um
is there not video maybe there's let's
go here
see if there's some video
a rant paul and no no no new video it
doesn't seem
it's just something that he something
then he that he said i'm sure there will
be videos soon
he'll give an interview he'll say
something oh the randy rainbow
randy rainbow you guys know randy
he's fantastic fantastic
musician fantastic satirist he's got a
new video out he might ding me for
playing it on here
what i mean by that is a copyright check
on youtube
uh but we'll play it for you guys to
listen to it uh let's see it's about
three minutes long
so uh let's let's play randy's video
and then we'll we'll we'll be we'll be
right back after we play randy's video
here let me let me do it it's dude
because i love randy's videos
here we go
i know
whatever oh i'll call you back welcome
back we are joined now by the most hated
woman in washington the reason it's a
bad idea to drink battery acid margery
taylor green marjorie thank you so much
for being with us during this difficult
time i understand they just suspended
your only fan's account well yes sir i
think it's very concerning as a matter
of fact i think it's terrifying i see it
as an attack really yeah who gives a
[ __ ] you've had a busy few weeks
speaking at white nationalist
conventions heckling the president's
state of the union tell us how do you
balance your day job as a bigoted
fame-hungry conspiracy theorist with
your personal life as a bigoted
hypocritical seditionist and overall
threat to civilization
and a mom
it's basically impossible because when
you become a public figure as you know
i'm sure you lose a lot of rights tell
me about it i slapped a barista at
starbucks the other day because he gave
me oat milk when i asked for almond and
then they wouldn't even give me my
rewards points on the order well we have
to stand up against the lies and thank
you for pointing that out it is it's
been unbelievable to me
the cdc has just announced that it's
tracking a viral trend of wacky twits
and there's a new strain of mutations at
large
some go by lauren and others by marge
they somehow spread to washington dc
all through the gop i don't know who's
running the federal government these
days uh joe biden or
prince john what's with this dame
she thinks
democracy's a game
and she's the same
so we refer to them both by one name
girl you're
[Applause]
and you appear to be missing a brain
[ __ ] stupid
[Applause]
[Music]
here she is folks the leader of the axe
who's she backing up now genghis khan
she's the nut job who's pro january 6th
and anti-facts has all her information
from fox news
oh wow gosh that's quite a list well ah
shut up get a clue go to hell
girl
and you get off on the bits that you
pitch
cause you're a carrot
you're just a racist ass basic white
don't make me say it [ __ ] you act
knowledge titled and muscles you
advocate hate and condemn this spatula
[Music]
gazpacho please
your privilege is whiter than anderson
cooper
hey daddy
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Applause]
thank you thank you randy rainbow
uh for giving us the the great karen
song
because you're a karen i think it's what
he's calling it uh thank you randy uh
for for that let's uh retweet randy's
video here and give him credit for being
on the [ __ ] list roundup
thank you
randy for your song all right let's go
back to the trinity trends and the tree
tweets here i believe that um candace
owens is also turning i'm not sure why
let's go in and see number 22 candace
owens
coming in at number 22 on the shitless
roundup
uh brian tyler cohen says new the
russian in uh the russian embassy in the
us has retweeted a tweet from candace
owens saying russia's russian lives
matter
a phrase being used as part of a
coordinated russian russian
disinformation campaign what in the
actual [ __ ]
like literally we said the other day and
and i believe this
fox news the right wing in this country
is producing russian content
like that's what they're doing they're
russian content creators
and here is evidence of it as candace
owens is apparently being retweeted
by the russian embassy which why in the
[ __ ] is the russian embassy still
allowed to tweet number one
and that against the the terms and
service
i'm sure of twitter
but apparently is tweeting that russian
lives matter
with the the obvious
trope there
ah
good lord
let's see
let's see if we can find
uh here uh
the jewish gender resistor has the
has the screenshot of candace owens
tweet absolutely appalling let's see
we'll do it this way absolutely
appalling the way the russians are being
treated in america and abroad oh my god
you have got to be [ __ ] kidding me
you've got to be kidding me
you see the russian embassy in the u.s
has retweeted this tweet appalling the
way the russians are being tweeted and
treated in america and abroad i'm going
to show you some [ __ ] videos here in
a second
i'm going to show you some videos here
in just a second
of
how bad the russians got it oh
they got it so bad
so awful
as soon as i'm done
raking this one through the coals
what our leaders and government
institutions are allowing that our
leaders and government institutions are
allowing for and at times calling for
this discrimination following their
global black lives matter hysteria is
quite telling
what
what the [ __ ] are you talking about this
ain't got
oh my god
frankly the sanctions that we have on
russian oligarchs and the russian people
will free them you dumb [ __ ]
free them from the fascism that you want
in this country
the only reason why vladimir putin is
going into ukraine and participating in
chaos around the world is because
democracy
is his [ __ ] enemy candace owens you
trunt
vladimir putin is not doing this because
ukraine bad
because ukraine the aggressor
you are a fascist and to be frank with
you candace owens if you're [ __ ]
listening when the fascists take over
this country like you want them to
you'll be the first to go
the first they won't need you anymore
you understand that right
you understand the role you play in the
fascist propaganda rather it's here in
this country or to prop up vladimir
[ __ ] putin
you would be the first
to go
[ __ ] ridiculous
jewish gender resistor says candace
owens wins the award for the most
grifting possible during a war
saying russian lives matter and proudly
having russians retweet you as putin
kills kids meanwhile black lives matter
is a terrorist group right comrades
maga equals party of family values yeah
[ __ ] these [ __ ]
disgusting thank you
jewish gender resistor
for your tweet
now let's get to
the
russians oh they can't monetize their
social media they can't monetize their
social media
uh here is one
that has been posted
now again i'm not gonna i'll play a
little bit of the video but you'll get
the gist of it
if you still harbor any sentimental
feelings towards ordinary russians
candace owens you trunt because of
sanctions here's a blogger crying about
the fact that she won't be able to
access her monetized instagram
not ukrainian civilians being buried in
mass graves
she is not crying
because innocent women and children are
being killed in ukraine
by putin she's crying
because she can't get on instagram
oh it's so awful
so awful you can't get on your instagram
too bad
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
want another one you want more i got
there's more than this thread you guys
should see this thread actually you know
what
i'm going to
quote tweet
this
thread
here we go here's more here's another
one
she says her house is burning down
that's the quote uh i don't i don't
speak russian so
meaning her ig account she's talking
about her instagram account when she's
sitting here crying saying her house is
burning down
there are literally [ __ ] people in
ukraine having their families their
children
their wives their husbands their
brothers their sisters being killed in
their own homes because vladimir putin
is throwing rockets and bombs and
committing war crimes he destroyed a
[ __ ] maternity hospital
and these ordinary russians that candace
owens is trying to defend
can't get on their instagram accounts
can't monetize their social media
[Music]
who
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
there's another disgusting one here in
this thread
this one here
this one says
this one is also having it
also having a normal one
she's displeased at the fact that the
instagram won't flag comments or post
about putin regime terrorists saying
it's the tolerant west
sound like woke talk there
that wanted to make us love
[ __ ] is the word that she uses here
that's that's the words that they're
using
you think you think they won't come for
you in this country
that's what they want they want this
putin [ __ ] in our
country that's what they want
here she is
listen
to instagram facebook
live
you think the russian people don't
aren't
indoctrinated into fascism what do you
think they want here why do you think
they're going after children here
whether they're
trans or gay rather their parents are
gay i'm telling you
i'm telling you
that's what they're going after that's
the march that they're on
they want american citizens making
videos like this
to spread their fascism
it's happening
here's more at this woman here
says uh having a breakdown over destroy
ukrainian towns nope she's not having a
breakdown she's pissed off about
instagram she says i always supported
you all your z
you guys have seen the z
just deported all those [ __ ]
ukrainians she says each and every post
of mine was about how great russia is
and now is
this is the poor poor poor russians
that candace owens is talking about they
can't monetize their instagram accounts
look
if the people of russia if the people
russia want to make sure that they can
monetize their instagram accounts maybe
just maybe maybe just maybe they should
go after the leader that is causing them
not
to be able to monetize
it's well past time it's well past time
to call vladimir putin what he is he's a
fascist murderous dictator and he won't
stop at ukraine
we had aaron parnez on last week and
even aaron said he's not going to stop
at ukraine that's not where he's
stopping on friday go watch the
interview it's on youtube
i posted just the interview on youtube
he's not going to stop just ukraine like
that's not just his goal he's gonna keep
going he wants poland he wants europe
why do you think he wants to kill nato
this ain't got nothing to do with
[ __ ] nato and ukraine ukraine isn't
even part of nato and even if vladimir
putin is worried about ukrainians being
or ukraine and for that matter being
part of nato because nato on my border
as soon as he takes over ukraine
poland is a nato border
it's all nonsense it's all [ __ ]
candace owen's saying it tucker carlson
saying it whoever the [ __ ] is out there
propagating
pro-putin [ __ ] are [ __ ] fascist and
they not only support putin they want
putin rule here
that's why they don't want nato
that's why they're so against
woke
democracy because woke democracy people
who are aware of how democracy works and
what liberty is
is a threat to their fascism
that they want
and the fascist states that they want
all around the world that's why vladimir
putin has been trying to show chaos in
all the democracies not just ours not
just ukraine canada
other in the in in europe
france
they don't
want democracy
and the reason why
is because they want fascism and
democracy is the enemy
of fascism
okay let's go back to the tweet tweets
and trendy trends
um
[Music]
uh the koch brothers also are traitors
it's not surprising subsidiaries of the
business conglomerate koch industries
have continued operations in russia amid
the ongoing conflict with ukraine
according to journalist judd lingam
uh judd here is the um
let's see i think this is probably the
tweet here with his article
he says following the russian invasion
of ukraine hundreds of corporations have
suspended their operations in russia
you guys have seen that we had
mcdonald's uh coca-cola several other
big
big food chains that's one of the other
videos that's in that thread so go to
that thread about those russians crying
and whining about about how they got cut
off from the world one of them is is
she can't get mcdonald's or doritos i
think it's the thing that she says she
can't get mcdonald's and doritos what is
she going to eat
one of the major exceptions is coke
industries the conglomerate run by
right-wing billionaire charles koch
following details and receipts um so
here i'll retweet this thank you judd
for your story
everyone follow along with judd
to see what uh subsidiaries here's the
thread here
are being
used to still do business
with
russia and to propagate
russia's terror around the world
um
so the koch brothers
we're 35 minutes into the second hour
let's see here
i'd say make sure i didn't miss anything
ah
tulsi
dolly parton coke industries candace
owens randy rainbow pfizer
pfizer
let's see if pfizer is still trending
uh that was that was one we were we were
looking for
of course we went to mansion
is trending now is there anything in
rand paul is now trending
you guys heard that
the tom brady is coming back right
oh [ __ ]
uh i don't mean it can be a conspiracy
theorist here i really don't
but it really is [ __ ] sus
it really is it's really it's really
[ __ ] suspicious
that tom brady says he's retiring
and then he says no no i'm not retiring
like like what has it been a week it
ain't been a [ __ ] week is it
i i don't mean it to be a conspiracy
theorist dear
maybe maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
the uh
they're trying to make sure that
americans don't figure out actually why
gas prices are so high
by distracting them with tom brady
i don't know
i don't know
i'm just snowballing here you tell me
you tell me what you think
just telling you
i think that's a thing all right let's
let's take a quick break
we'll be right back
after this message
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop left you
customized from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging with us through the
break there
uh
um
i have uh some more video that i wanted
to show you here
and i'm trying to find it on my timeline
oh here it is
this is a gabe
speaking of fascist
and
you guys know madison gother and of
course the nazi
some people call him sitler
i would never call him that um sitler i
would never call him zittler even though
that's probably um that's probably where
it is
um
but um
gabe gabriel did this video
gabriel did this video of madison
gawthorne here and put it to some music
and also some sound effects let's make
sure i got the volume up let's let's uh
let's watch
let's watch this mayo says i can't stand
that dude yeah he can't stand him either
oh
burn okay
[Music]
i wish
you hear the little grunts
you hear the little grunts of the edit
gabe says i found madison catherine in
the woods again looks like he's working
through some things right now
hilarious okay let's let's go let's go
back to the timeline uh
i know there was some more video that i
wanted to show you here
oh yes over the weekend kellyanne conway
was trending
uh she claimed on fox news
i think it was on friday here's a
kellyanne
talking about alternative facts in
crisis and joe biden that he has this
way jen saki of playing the blame and
game name and shame
nonsense of washington but it would rely
on the american people believing it and
they've lost credibility not just in
their message and their messengers you
know laura i like to say the democrats
don't have this administration doesn't
have
a messaging problem they have a fact
problem oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
okay
let's see
someone says they're sending me uh some
video
you say you've sent me some video robin
uh
check my
doo doo doo
sorry i'm just trying to see this
someone's trying to send me a video
that you want me to believe
[Music]
me me me robin says me me me okay well
which video is it
look in here
is it the music video
hold on is that is that the one that
you're you're referring to
is there another video on twitter
okay we'll try it
oh you're sitting on sunday okay let's
look here
um is this the tennessee senate
the the
okay all right here we go
yes i remember i remember this now
okay we're gonna play robin's video here
you guys know that you guys can dm me or
or you can you can just
tag me
if you want to try to get some stuff on
the shitless roundup you can always just
tag me
if uh if you if you
can't dm me now again the only way i
think you can demon i got it set to
where i have to follow you and you have
to follow me and if i don't follow you
on twitter that's okay dude no big deal
just down in one of my one of my tweets
just say hey i want you to follow me and
even if i don't get to it the first time
just keep telling me until i follow you
right i it's it's no big deal i'll
follow you
just
send it to me and i'll try to
i'll try to get it done and then that
way you can dm me so if you want to dm
me some stuff
uh and and as the dms fill up and get
fuller maybe we'll have to have a
different way of doing that because uh
my dm's do get full sometimes so i miss
them sometimes uh but here we have uh
the tennessee senate has approved
jordan uh
mullenhauer i think is his name mullen
or jordan muller hour governor bill
who is a republican pick for state board
of education
uh
more an hour mullin hour owns lucky
gunner an online ammo store in 2018
lucky gunner the ammo store that owns
sold rounds to a 17 year old two months
later he gunned down 10 people in a
santa fe high school
that's that seems significant let's
listen to this here mr jordan
mullenhauer of knoxville uh the governor
has appointed mr mullenhauer to the
state board of education for a term that
will expire on march 31st 2026. mr
mullenhauer is a respected member of his
community in the knoxville area i am
curious whether the governor
when making this appointment was aware
that this nominee is named individually
in litigation alleging that
he and his company illegally sold
ammunition to juveniles which was then
used
in one of the largest school shootings
in our nation's history
i am aware that there was litigation and
if i'm not mistaken i believe the
litigation was dismissed in a federal
district court i don't know mr
mullenhauer but i have read his bio and
as i mentioned in my description of the
the resolution there mr mullenhauer is a
very successful business person um there
i believe with regards to the situation
you referenced there has been no
allegation whatsoever of any type of
criminal activity so it is a civil
litigation but he is but mr rolling our
individually
is accused of having acted in violation
of
a criminal statute 18 usc
226.
that's what the allegation in that comp
net claim
in that lawsuit is
is that they violated the criminal code
of the united states and it's not
you know where he's an investor this is
a company that that that that mr olinar
found
like he he owns it in its entirety i
believe
and if the administration didn't
know
the full details about this
well i mean that's inexcusable but if
they did know that's worse
there are seven million people in this
state
like we ought to be able to find one
who's not involved in ongoing litigation
about
possible responsibility in a school
shoot but we should know what the real
information is
on this before going down this path and
potentially making a
appointment to a nine-member board that
raises this kind of
issue and frankly threatens to undermine
confidence in the board and uh senator
jeff yarbrough here is right like
there's there's a lot of other people in
this [ __ ] state why can't we find one
[ __ ] who's qualified to be on
the the board of education for [ __ ]
sake who has a tenure till
2026 in tennessee
think about this this isn't an
accomplice in a school shooting
they're an accomplice they didn't sell
legally ammo to someone and that person
happened
just happen to mow down a bunch of
students at a high school they illegally
sold a minor ammunition online
through this lucky gunner
and by the way by the way him being a
successful business person has [ __ ]
nothing to do with him sitting on the
state board of education
why does anyone think just because you
you [ __ ] make profit off people
killing each other and people killing
other people
and you stoke fear in this country with
fascism just because you profit off that
think makes you a good business person
number one that does not but number two
what in the [ __ ] does being a good
business person have anything to do with
being on the board of education in the
state of tennessee i'm sure there are
plenty of current and retired teachers
that would be more than happy and more
than qualified and more than willing to
take this position on the state board of
education who [ __ ] know something
about education
not about selling ammunition to minors
so that they can go mow down students in
a school somewhere
i think that's probably appropriate i
don't know like a [ __ ] teacher of a
school administrator
retired or otherwise
might know a little [ __ ] more about
the board of education
than some [ __ ] businessman who
profits off the death of [ __ ] school
children
profits off the death of school children
do you notice a [ __ ] trend here with
the gqp
they [ __ ] love oh they [ __ ] love
they [ __ ] love them some people who
will who
who actually hate [ __ ] children oh
they [ __ ] love it they [ __ ] love
it
i mean that is the pro-life [ __ ] way
these days with the gqp
damn damn damn the person who has the
uterus his life and their liberty [ __ ]
them [ __ ] their liberty
as a matter of fact we might just put
them we are so pro-life we just might
put them to death if they have a medical
procedure to save their life
and by the way if we force them to have
the baby and that baby grows up to be a
17 year old who wants to buy ammunition
illegally online
[ __ ] a right we will especially if
they want to go mow down school children
not to mention if that [ __ ] person
grows up to be a great business person
who profits off the death of school
children we really like that
[ __ ] you notice a trend with the
pro-life gqp do you notice a [ __ ]
trend
they're a death cult
they've never believed any of that
[ __ ] that pro-life
[ __ ]
they're not pro-life they never have
been they never [ __ ] will be
count it
count it
robin says gop hates women
they hate women they hate children
and she says they hate america you're
right robin thank you for the video
you knew
[Laughter]
i think robin knew
i think
robin knew that would get my uh
get my rant going
that's
that's what she was trying to get out of
me
was a rant
and there you go maybe i'll cut it out
and uh
put that [ __ ] on twitter all by itself
all by itself
all by itself
we are 50 minutes
50 minutes into the second hour let's
check the tree tweets and attorney
trends and see what we have left
i'd like to play the uh everyone likes
the
the letters of the trucker convoy
and i like to play those one more time
for everybody they're they're just so
fantastic they really are uh we had a
lot of fun making them uh like i said
let's go see if i can find the uh
the tweet
that uh jojo i'll read that to you
here live in the voice of bob
see if i can find that tweet
uh
[Music]
see if i can find that tweet
and then we'll play the uh we'll play
the trucker convoy
uh number one and number two here we go
so this is this is the oh here here it
is this is the tweet from jill that gave
me the inspiration
so she wrote this
let's see was it friday or was it
saturday it was the 12th so this would
have been this would have been saturday
she wrote this she wrote this saturday
in the morning
when i seen it i was like oh my gosh i
read it in this voice
dearest tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong
in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slam gems and skull
but near ran out of natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob
like that's the voice i read it in and
then she has hashtag letters from the
trucker convoy
and i just i seen this vision of like a
ken burns documentary style video
of this back and forth between tammy and
bob
and she followed it up let me give her
credit here
thanks for the tweet there okay and she
follows it up with this reply
which is uh which is hilarious
she says dear bob i'm fixing to send you
some more of them doritos you like the
red bag not the lib loving blue one in
your absence i discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey i ain't
even seen my cousin brody in ages stay
strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
so that's where it started and you guys
can keep following uh she kept wrote
writing them here's the the one that uh
that the where the flipping off we had
to change it a bit because of the video
but
um so go go check out the um
the trucker convoy but let's let's watch
the see if we can go back to the
[Music]
let's go back to the videos here
um for the trucker convoy
here we go
here's the first one that gabe
released
here it is
letters from the truckers convoy let me
uh let me do this proper let me get the
that off the screen let's do that there
all right let's let's listen one more
time too
the letters from the truckers convoy
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
wait was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy so that's the first one
that's the first one and then let's
watch the uh let's give gabe credit here
and then let's watch the second one here
this is uh letters from the trucker
convoy part two
possibly part three may be being
released soon let's let's listen to part
two
letters from the trucker convoy
part two
dears tammy
today was a dark day
there i was minding my own business
cruising around the beltway
went up come a mess of young girls
and they done gave me the middle finger
it wasn't like the normal finger it was
real mean like
now i'm scared
send nudes
bomb
dear bob
don't let them comment with girls that
flip you off get y'all upset
remember why you're there you're there
cuz
well
i don't really know why you're there but
don't you lose sight of it
whatever
it is
well here's a pic of my tits
sorry about the rash
stay strong
here's
tammy
[Laughter]
so letters from the trucker convoy part
two i i want to i want to thank joe and
gabe for the
for the alley oops on those videos again
when i read that first tweet uh on
saturday
i uh
i just
i read it in that voice and i seen the
ken burns documentary and uh joe kept
writing gabe kept making the videos
and they made that they made that uh
piece of piece of little art possible so
hopefully we'll do more parts to the
letters of the trucker convoy and then
maybe maybe like when we when we i don't
know how long we can go with this thing
like i don't know how long ago i have no
idea i know how long we'll be able to
keep it up and maybe they'll continue
the trucker convoy maybe bob and tammy
can keep going as well
maybe they can keep going even past the
trucker convoy
i don't know i don't know we'll see and
then maybe we'll just string them
together so it's one long like ken burns
story like with the story just keeps
continuing and continuing and we have
the saga of of tammy and bob
uh someone asked here in the chat uh
nancy asks can someone tell if tony is
live every day monday through friday at
what time thanks in advance nancy
we are live every single weekday monday
through friday
12 eastern 11 central time
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch you can find all those places and
all those channels where we stream live
you can find it on
thetonymichaels.com the link in my bio
the tonymichaels.com all the podcast
uh stations are there whether it's the
youtube twitter twitch we also if you
wanna listen to the podcast
if you wanna listen to the podcast
instead of look at my beautiful face you
just wanna hear my beautiful voice when
i have it you guys know last week
or the week before i had a little
struggle with my voice but when i have
my voice my beautiful beautiful voice if
you want to just listen to it
you can download the podcast on all the
directories even the boycotted ones
apple spotify google i heart radio you
name it it's on there go to
podcast.tonymichael thetonymichaels.com
or just go to thetonymichaels.com you
can click on all those places where you
can download the podcast or just search
the tony michaels podcast wherever you
listen to your podcast
or wherever you want to see it you can
see it here on twitter you can see it on
youtube you can see it on twitch and by
the way if you're downloading it on
those directories wherever you're
downloading it
make sure to give us a five star review
make sure that helps us out make sure
you like and subscribe to the youtube
channel make sure if you're over on
twitch you follow us there follow us
follow us on twitter as well
at
tonymichaelspod and then follow me at
the tony michaels and follow gabe i am
gabe sanchez to keep up with everything
going on here at the show the tony
michaels podcast as you know the recent
uh news we are with the midas touch
media network
as well so go go look at all those
podcastes too what what i am so excited
about with being with my dis touch media
network is they really are pro-democracy
that's their focus and that's the
media's focus rather it be legal af
rather it be politics girls lee mcgowan
rather be the weeknd show now with
anthony davis
rather it's it's the actual midas touch
podcast with the three brothers or
zoomed in with aaron and and jack or the
kremlin file or now now you can go watch
michael cohen's milecopa on youtube on
their youtube channel
go follow all those podcasts as well
hopefully we'll have more and more of
those people on the show to talk about
their show but more importantly to talk
about the content of their show because
i know all you out there are
pro-democracy that's why you listen to
this show that's why you listen to all
those shows as well whether it be
politics girl the minus touch podcast
uh legal af
whichever one that that you listen to
are all of them
we appreciate you listening make sure to
subscribe to the youtube channel check
out the merch store also if you're on
thetonymichaels.com we got the [ __ ]
hats we got [ __ ] shirts over there
that helps the podcast and also if
you're available for the podcast upgrade
fun that would be great one more
announcement we also have super chat
here on youtube if you're not familiar
with super chat it is a great way for
you to support the podcast
during the chat on the youtube
live so join us live
every single weekday again
every single weekday monday through
friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
every single weekday live
youtube twitter twitch
follow us subscribe like
and until tomorrow
until tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking